so let the hilarious fawning begin
those lights that are that are just
shooting out from the lincoln memorial
uh along the reflecting pool i look it's
like almost
extensions of joe biden's arms embracing
america it was a moment where the new
president came to town
and sort of convened the country in this
moment of remembrance
outstretching his arms
wow tubin really let himself go but wait
there's more the 46th
president of the united states putting
his soul into his first address
he gave the kind of inaugural address
our presidents used to give
as hopeful as the man delivering it we
saw the steely determination
and compassion of president joe biden
what a great love story between
jill biden and joe biden we haven't had
a love story in the white house
in four years
it is a love story between the press and
biden the new york times editor
even admits she got chills from joe
which we hope
isn't coveted meanwhile as the corporate
press
drools for joe they frantically spit on
the outgoing guy trying to outdo each
other
on who's more relieved that our national
nightmare is over
a welcome sight for many americans
president trump is leaving washington
it's going to be a little pathetic a
tiny little crowd at joint base andrews
he's almost leaving town like a uh
an autocrat he just looks like a small
man
he knows he is leaving a pariah and
nobody wants to be seen with him
four years ending with true american
carnage a riot
a pandemic carnage
it's amazing the emotional intensity
of their conformity the media is so
predictable you could set your watch to
their lock step
the press are like children overjoyed
that mommy's deadbeat boyfriend finally
moved out of the house
except they still can't quit america's
bad boy at all
nope trump has actually left a
trump-sized hole in their lives
and they're trying to figure out how to
fill it and with what
well the media coverage will bounce
between softcore fluffery
masquerading is hard news example hey
did you hear joe as a peloton i got two
sources to go on record
to pieces that remember the awful past
under the fonzie godzilla hybrid that
was trump
don't worry there will be no anonymous
sources feeding blitz or
false stories of biden meltdowns and in
the media's gassy stew
you'll see the regret what will they do
after all their bitter emotional
farewells
when they realize their primary engine
of profit creating conflict and hate
based on their own loathing for trump is
finally gone
let's ask mara a lot of americans of
goodwill
saw the true face of white supremacy and
of
trumpism at its core what is preventing
us
from coming together to fight our real
enemies like covet
is racism it is at the heart of what
allowed donald trump
free reign to terrorize the american
people for four years
yes trump may be gone but you the
possibly racist person who voted for him
you're still here but not for long if
they can help it
and by they i mean media katie who have
gone
beyond parody i get it greatest
inauguration
ever but come on greg i have another one
for you uh all the fashion magazines
including refinery29 said today dr biden
is bringing american fashion back into
the white house
starting with this subtle sparkly coat
now i loved the outfit that first lady
jill biden was wearing today
but first lady melania trump was a
supermodel
and a designer of high fashion so
you know they're gonna do what they're
gonna do yeah get ready for it four
years
their first opportunity is tonight with
the press secretary who will be out at
seven o'clock to ask the follow-up
questions of
the executive orders today which i'm
sure will be in the honeymoon period
yeah you know juan i uh express my
opinions here this is a discussion show
we don't pretend to be
hard news as esteemed as that is
yet these are people that pretend to be
objective news anchors
who are drooling drooling as they're
watching an event
we can do that we're commentariats but
they're hard news
seems to me like a betrayal of america's
trust
now i don't see it that way i think that
in fact what you have is in
america more opinion and opinion i wish
we would get back to more
simple facts but some people might say
that was boring i do think that
what you see in the conservative echo
chamber greg is you know
constant campaign political barbs
attacks
nicknames uh bullying i just don't like
it and i think that that sells for
a lot of people so the campaigning never
stops so we never get to like
solving problems for the country we
never get to talk about compromise
people who want to compromise they're
dismissed as weak
uh you know as quizlings this they're
terrible and so
the emphasis is always on selling
grievance selling grudges
picking fights i mean i guess that's
what gets the person to come back and
listen to the next show but
to me that's not what government should
be about it should be in the name of
the american people and the best
interest of the american people
yeah i think brett kavanaugh would agree
with you after what those republicans
did oh wait it wasn't republicans
hey jesse um this is why when we look at
this stuff you cannot trust this
industry
this industry that we are in is the lead
because you watch them just
transform their belief system or their
their fat
their their their mentality depending on
the party it's amazing
well juan said yesterday that people's
personal politics shouldn't affect their
job performance
so when you heard all those hard news
reporters
saying trump's a white supremacist that
was not
affected at all by their personal
politics he has been proven to be
a card-carrying white supremacist that's
hard news right juan
of course not that's their opinion
infecting
their job and that's what the problem is
last word to you dana we don't pick
sides here
but they do don't they well
let me just say one thing that the biden
team has benefited from they are
extremely tight-lipped they do not leak
so far
um that might change now that they're at
the white house but on the campaign like
reporters extremely frustrated
they had a disciplined approach if they
can bring that to the white house their
dealings with the media will probably be
better
all right not sure